Film Courage: Robin, for any actor who wants
to be a working actor in Hollywood, what are
some things that they need to know not just
about the business but also themselves?
Robin Riker, actor/author: You have to have
a good sense of yourself and a good thick
skin.
It’s very odd that an actor needs to be
able to shed that skin immediately and be
able to be vulnerable and express feelings.
You must have thick skin because you are not
going to get more jobs that you get.
Even the most famous actors the ones who you
think work all the time don’t get every
job they want and as a working actor (we working
actors) don’t get more jobs than we do.
So you have to know that, you just have to
know that.
And then you have to act.
I encourage (alas equity is making this a
little difficult for equity actors but you
have to perform.
So find a class to go to that keeps your instrument
lubricated and working so you know you’re
not going in and trying to read for MacBeth
after not doing anything for six months or
doing cereal commercials.
So find a workshop some place where you can
work and do scenes and scene study and that
sort of thing.
You have to be very careful of becoming a
professional student.
A lot of people come here and take classes
and that satisfies them in a way.
Even doing really good work in a class is
not the same as working and so you have to
do that work in order to be able to be good
enough to land work.
This is not the same as working.
And so you have to do that work in order to
be able to be good enough to land that work.
So you have to get on stage as often as you
can.
There are lots of little theaters here that
do plays.
If you’re not equity you can do that.
If you are equity you have to do some workarounds
to get that happening now alas.
But get on stage as much as you can so you
are warmed up.
You should always before you go out on an
audition you should be as prepared as you
can possibly be but for yourself (this is
not so much for the audition) but for the
person, go somewhere in public before you
go to the audition.
Because you are a human who is trying to display
emotions and if you make this audition the
most important thing of your day “I’m
getting ready for this.
I can’t do anything before this.
This is it, the focus, the focus, the focus,”
then you get in the room and you’re not
limber.
So I always try to go and have a cup of coffee
or pick up my dry-cleaning or chat with somebody,
go get something from the market, do something
so I’m limber and I’ve had a conversation
with someone before I’m having my first
conversation with you the casting director
who hold my future in your hands.
So that’s one thing that I think is very
important and on the flip side of that at
the end of the audition go somewhere fun,
reward yourself, you know?
Have something to look forward to because
a lot of times you go in…you can tell, you
can read the room whether they received you
well or not…you can’t always tell because
there have been times when I’ve gone in
thinking I’ve stunk up the room and got
a call a few hours later that I’ve got a
job, so you can’t really judge by that.
But if you’ve made the audition or the interview
the most important moment of your day then
you’re very likely to feel this huge letdown
at the end of it or this artificial sort of
stiffness at the beginning because you haven’t
been a person.
Film Courage: I like that…that’s excellent.
Robin: So those I think are the most important
things because everybody has different levels
of talent so I can’t really speak to that.
But those things, you have to understand that
you’re not going to get more jobs than you
do, you have to understand that nobody gets
your job, you get your job.
And never talk about having lost a job when
it was only an audition, you didn’t loose
anything.
You can’t loose anything you didn’t have.
And go out somewhere before the audition to
limber up and have somewhere fun to go after
the audition to celebrate because you went
to work.
Film Courage: I absolutely love that in terms
of interacting with people and loosing that
sort of social phobia that we all have.
Because we’re all in a hurry and were like
“I don’t have much time and there is lots
of traffic” and now LA is a little bit more
crowded than it used to be so we are even
more dialed in on directly where we need to
be but go somewhere fun, go to Trader Joe’s
and pick up something.
Robin: Exactly, chat with the guys or girls
or something.
Make something happen…live!
Do something to get yourself person-ized again
instead of focused on the job.
Film Courage: Right.
Let’s talk about when you get the job.
How should one conduct themselves on set even
if they have a scene where they are only going
to cross in front of the camera or they have
several lines of dialogue?
Robin: First of all, the crew is usually comprised
of real people who are not full of themselves
and are willing to share information with
you, you know?
Meet you AD who is going to tell you where
the dressing rooms are and be nice to the
craft service person, be nice to everyone.
Here is one thing that you must know for sure…if
someone of the regular cast is nice to you
and reaches out to you, it will be a rarity.
I am amazed at the number of people who have
every reason to be kind and open to the guest
stars or co-stars who come on the show who
won’t even give them the time of day, just
don’t expect it, don’t expect that.
You be nice, take care of yourself, you be
kind.
If someone is nice and sweet to you, be nice
and sweet back but don’t try and suddenly
become their best friend because that’s
just going to backfire on you in a major way.
Ask questions, feel free to ask questions
but don’t expect that you are going to be
embraced to the company because it doesn’t
happen very often, unless it’s my show because
I make sure I do that because I know how difficult
it can be to be the day player on the set
or the one in for three days or something
and I’ve always made it the point to welcome
(I think that’s probably the theater thing
again, the pot of chili and the glass of wine
concept).
But that’s what they should do, but be on
time, always be on time.
It’s a good idea to bring a magazine or
book and a comfy pillow with you.
Have a little set bag because you spend a
lot of time waiting and you want to be comfortable
when you do and most of the trailers and dressing
rooms don’t have a comfy pillow or reading
material for you to pass the time with.
If you have any special dietary needs or prohibitions,
make sure you take care of yourself in that
regard.
Bring a snack or two that fits those things
and be prepared to wait and check.
If you feel you’ve been waiting a long time
and you’re kind of losing the edge check
with your AD and is it likely “can you give
me an E.T.A.
I’d 15 minutes before you need me, if at
all possible?”
You may not be able to get that 15 but that’s
why you say “If at all possible?”
And you can remember I’d love to pump up
for when it’s time to go.
And know your lines and be prepared to enjoy
yourself and do a good job.
Film Courage: I like what you said too about
be friendly but not try to be someone’s
best friend and then on the flip side knowing
that people “Oh!
I can’t wait to work with so-and-so!”
and know that they may not see you and not
be hurt.
Robin: Perfectly said.
Film Courage: Because I think there is the
armor you have to wear and I think you learn
it after a few years of being here but when
you’re new especially you get really…it’s
easy to get hurt.
Or it’s easy to become someone’s best
friend right away and then find out…you
never hear from them again and you’re shocked!
Robin: Right!
Right!
Film Courage: But can you talk about that
armor?
And it’s not being a mean person, it’s
just being protective.
Robin: Yeah…but I also…it’s not being
a mean person.
You are more generous than I in that regard,
I find that they are not being a conscious
person.
If you can say “Hello!
Welcome to the show, nice to have you.”
Now one of the reasons they may not do that
is because when they have done that, the newbie
has decided “Oh now, she’s my best friend.
I’m going to talk to her, we are going to
have lunch together, whatever.
And that person’s wants “Get off of me!”
Maybe they are protecting themselves because
they have done this before and it kind of
backfired on them in a way that they didn’t
want to have to deal with.
Film Courage: True.
Robin: However, it is easy to take a moment
to welcome someone to your show, to be kind
to them, to have a nice word, because we are
all doing it together.
Everyone is in the same boat.
You have a better seat perhaps than I do if
you’re the regular on the show but we’re
in the same boat and we’re all actors and
performers.
So I find that sort of treatment…I was doing
an episode…and while the make-up lady was
doing her make-up her face was down like this
in her cell phone the whole time.
She didn’t speak to anyone, she didn’t
say…now she maybe a perfectly lovely girl.
I worked with her for a week, she seemed very
nice on the set.
But I use that as an example as how you as
a co-star or a guest star (or any star should
be) on the show is that the people that are
there, the make-up, the hair, they are not
your servants, they are professionals that
are doing their job.
Treat them with dignity and respect because
they have control over how you look.
You are allowed to say “I prefer to have
my hair blown forward rather than blown back
or I would like to have it up if possible
blah, blah, blah, you can tell them what it
is you want you can do it as though you are
speaking to a professional and say please
and thank you and be a conscious human being.
Don’t…you know they are not your staff.
Film Courage: Sure.